foreign
bust of Nancy Reagan and to be clear I'm
not talking about Nancy Reagan's bust
well I guess technically now I am
talking about her bust and her bust but
not the bust of her bust I think I'm not
sure whose Twisted idea it was to put
hundreds of adolescents in underfunded
schools well the first Public School in
the U.S probably started a long time ago
in a former Colony somewhere on the East
Coast it's weird that someone as
inquisitive as Wednesday would settle on
a public schools how do they work also
Wednesday aeration done by people whose
dreams were crushed years ago crushed
I'd say with these pants in this tie
more like crushing it why do the bullies
in this school have what looks like
multi-colored rope readily available and
in such a supply that they're all
wasting it on tying up kids in lockers
convenient psychic vision is convenient
what are you gonna do what I do best
choreograph a dance number that fits
your personality perfectly by listening
to Susie and the Banshees but still be
able to pull it off to a random cramp
song did I just have a vision one can
only hope so the sin as always is dance
numbers we won't play the song but what
we have here is a non General
cliche the only person who gets to
torture my brother is me this is a funny
scene but where the did she get
that many piranhas or really any
Piranhas from they're showing affection
and then there's being so horny that it
looks like you might in front of your
kids and we are way too close to the
wrong side of that scale I merely meant
that finally you will be among peers
but what about Pugsley he was the one
getting constantly bullied at the other
school why aren't they sending him to
Nevermore or somewhere else as well
darling we aren't the ones who got you
expelled fair point but was getting
expelled the only punishment Wednesday
got even if no one died from her piranha
prank that should still be at the very
least attempted murder I never had a
problem without cast production team
gave this guy a red vest instead of a
red shirt did your mother tell you we
were roommates back in the day and you
graduated with your sanity intact
impressive kids not a hugger got it now
without giving you her explicit consent
Enid bring the room we imagine
K-State Wednesday to the registrar's
office to pick it up along with a copy
of her schedule schedule welcome to the
quad to Pentagon Wednesday would be
woefully overqualified at TV since let
me give you a Wiki on Nevermore Social
Scene giving people wikis those are the
things AKA vampires some of them have
literally been here for decades what the
are you telling me the
administration is just letting adults
fraternize with adolescents
look at you my little death
any lament titles for your kids bring
nicknames and on that note I'd like to
be called The Wiz if it isn't already
taken it's made of obsidian which part
of this is supposed to be obsidian the
little holes that most of these are
obsidian inlays Show's not giving us any
clear reason why the costume Department
couldn't give Deputy Santiago a hat
Wednesday removed the gels from the
windows because she is allergic to color
but this will also allow more sunlight
into the room which is basically all the
colors at the same time good evening
girls oh sorry about the mud you should
be saying sorry to the janitor is going
to clean up all the mud you've tracked
in from the front door to what seems
like the penthouse also 1990s Wednesday
is now greeting 2020's Wednesday and I'm
really dreading all the fan fiction that
literally just wrote itself and you must
be the self-appointed queen bee
interesting thing about bees pull out
their stingers and they drop dead all
living things can die or be mortally
wounded in one way or another
interesting thing about dialogue it also
dies if you remove its point for the
final point I would like to invoke a
military challenge no masks no tips
winner draws First Blood the idea that
any school even one was supernatural
creatures would allow this to happen is
absurd pissed off siren mothers can sue
just as easily as pissed off human
mothers the last thing I remember I was
walking outside feeling a mixture of
Rage pity and self-discus puberty all
the anachronisms in Brooklyn can't
excuse you for using a typewriter in
2022 instead of a computer my parents
aren't worried about me they're evil
puppeteers who want to pull my strings
even from afar Wednesday accusing her
Illuminati parents of conspiring against
her when we all know most of their
energy is dedicated to mastering the
horizontal Mambo ruining your nails and
your smooth Supple skin how is things
skin smooth and supple even if you
moisturize often walking around on your
hand all day it's gonna take its toll
principal Weems giving the middle finger
to Vermont's front plate laws perhaps
afterwards we can visit the weather Fame
for hot chocolate principal Williams
this feeble attempt at bonding is
beneath you turning down hot chocolate
with Gwendolyn Christy but someone who
crochets for a hobby is in a worthy
adversary my grandmother has entered the
chat with an uncanny ability to adopt
new technologies and way more knowledge
about every war since WW2 than one would
have initially expected listen Wednesday
one fun fact about me I can't be bought
saying this when presenting something
that is neither fun nor a fact what's a
never more freak going out in the wild
says the guy dressed up like a pilgrim
my dad owns Pilgrim world I refuse to
believe that any heir to the pilgrim
World Fortune would be able to be this
serious about it spinning cello time is
the most unlikely and unnecessary
successor of the Matrix is bullet time
also we won't play it but Paint It Black
is so on the nose here that I hate
myself for enjoying it looking at books
looking at files drinking warm drawer
beers suspense I had an extra hand
where's the rest of him it's one of the
great Adams Family Mysteries I'll agree
that's probably a question better left
unanswered but the writer's bringing up
the question just to dodge it isn't the
least bit Artful I've been to the best
lycanologists had to fight in Milwaukee
would you believe it they're the best
like anologists are in Milwaukee or that
Enid would actually go to Milwaukee and
I'm just gonna go ahead and call
on both possibilities because
Milwaukee thing being all like hey I
just met you and this is crazy but
here's my number so call me Wednesday
see
like your pit
I think giving the finger will never not
be funny so for this show when one goes
up one comes down would you mind
distracting her this works before you
leave wanted you to have this but if
Tyler's taking her to the train then he
can just give it to her in the car or
when they get to the train why is he
holding up the situation when he knows
Wednesday has to get out of there before
principal Weems catches her
Tyler you know scary you're just kind of
kooky
this will kick off the plot to me and
Chase that should be squashed pretty
quickly by calling for and or looking
for these strangely absent cops that
generally are required to be at most
carnivals fairs and festivals now the
show has been in the Harry Potter Vibe
for more of a stranger things feel but
instead of being cool it's more like
they cross the streams girl in the
picture that's you using the old out of
context picture is a piece of evidence
to build a case for your misguided
heroism cliche my mother said it was my
destiny to stop this girl if she ever
came to Nevermore parents are the worst
like don't even listen to them wait that
that's a terrible lesson I guess listen
to them sometimes maybe but not when it
comes to Magic Destinies or anything
related to Edgar Allan poems
this floating paper went to the Forrest
Gump feather School of forced dramatic
timing this season on Wednesday spoilers
now about this balding school you don't
think they'll make me take gym class do
you because those tight shorts show off
my problem area be sure and tell them
large marks sent you the Black Dahlia oh
you know it horrible one of the worst
movies ever made for the final point I
would like to invoke power quiet talking
forcing you to lean in and wonder if
you're missing any key phrases you made
me bleed my own blood option two bend
the knee and I will name you Warden of
the North
so where do you learn those Kung Fu
moves I watched my whole church group
get eaten by a bear